we're starting to see a softening
in the pandemic recovery and yeah some
of it has to do with anti-vaxxers
um what has been a fantastic you know 80
85
even 90 recovery from the pandemic and i
mean economically and i also mean from a
public health standpoint
is now slowing down now you might be
saying whoa hold david wait a second
are you criticizing the state of play
in the united states during a democratic
administration i thought you were a
democratic shill
or a shiel as someone recently called me
uh no
you you guys know many of you know i've
never been a democrat i don't really
care about the democratic party
i just call things the way they are and
we are now seeing jobless claims
up and higher than expected initial
jobless claims
uh for the week ending july 3rd came in
at 373
000 new jobless claims that's higher
than the 350 000 that was expected
initial unemployment claims had been on
the decline big picture for months now
but we're now seeing a reversal jobless
claims going up
meanwhile there are broader concerns
about the global economic comeback
anecdotally japan
has now declared a state of emergency in
tokyo
and covet cases are surging globally
they're surging in a number of countries
and overall and they're also up a bit
actually close to 20 percent in the
united states
check out these numbers around the world
cases had
bottomed out in mid-june at about 360
000 a day globally cases are now
up 12 just in the last few weeks to over
400
000 cases a day this is believed to be
mostly because of the more contagious
delta variant these
you know sometimes people see something
on the news more contagious delta
variant that doesn't really mean
anything no
we're seeing because it spreads more
easily 12
more cases globally per day there's now
an even more contagious
lambda variant we don't yet know much
about it which could be
the next to spread and become dominant
so cases
up 12 globally in the united states
cases are up 20 we had gotten down to
about
12 000 cases a day in the us we are now
up to more than 14 000 cases a day
in the u.s that is a big jump now so far
fortunately we are not seeing higher
deaths but remember that deaths lag
cases by weeks
the hope would be the optimistic
scenario is
even though we're seeing more cases
because delta's more contagious
if you're vaccinated you still are
unlikely to get hospitalized
if you get the virus and you're unlikely
to die if you get the virus if you are
vaccinated that's the hope
we don't really know that yet we need
another three to four weeks to see if
that's the case and meanwhile
20 of americans still don't want the
vaccine
if you care about public health you
would go and you would get the vaccine
if you care about the economy you would
go and you would get the vaccine
if you care about avoiding another sort
of shutdown to some degree in the fall
you would go and you get the vaccine
what are we doing here let's put up this
pathetic chart of u.s vaccinations per
day
and you will see if you were watching
today that we are basically down to the
level of daily vaccination that we saw
in january
now think back to that okay in january
we had almost no vaccines it was
healthcare workers and i think we were
starting to make the vaccine available
to the oldest and most vulnerable we are
vaccinating the same amount of people
now when we have full availability you
just walk in
in many places you don't even need an
appointment you just get vaccinated and
somehow
we are vaccinating no more people over
the last week
than we were doing in mid-january when
availability was close to
not not literally zero but it was very
very low
and in other countries people are just
sitting
there waiting for the privilege of
having the vaccine access
that we have and we are seeing it
reflected not just in the case numbers
but in the economic uncertainty as well
and so my appeal is
if you don't care about other people if
you don't care about
if you just don't want to get vaccinated
because you have assessed that you are
at low risk either accurately or not and
you don't really care about other people
or whatever else
do you care about the economy because
the economy
is wrapped up in the success of the
public health recovery
come on guys the world is desperate for
the vaccines that we have
an overflow of just go and get
vaccinated
let me know your thoughts on this do you
think that this will continue to worsen
or is this a temporary blip as we
hopefully
get closer and closer to herd immunity
let me know you can find me on twitter
at deepakman and we will see i mean
listen but
10 days from now we'll have the answer
and hopefully
it is a positive one and not a negative
one for the longest time
i was having trouble finding snacks that
are healthy but
actually taste great and fill me up and
satisfy
a craving and that's why it's great that
i stumbled upon
monk pack and we asked them to be one of
our sponsors
monk pack keto nut and seed bars are
delicious
snacks that have one gram of sugar or
less
only two to three grams of net carbs and
just 150 calories perfect for a
keto or low carb diet or anybody who
like me
just prefers to eat a low sugar diet i
love the monk pack keto nut and seed
bars
because it's really just a great balance
of sweet and salty soft and chewy
but with a nice crunch from the nuts and
seeds flavors include
caramel or caramel you tell me sea salt
sea salt dark chocolate and peanut
butter dark chocolate that's my favorite
they'll give you all of your money back
if you don't love it go to monkpack.com
the link is down below
and they'll give you 20 off any of their
products when you use coupon code pacman